نعم بدات مراسم تشييع الشهداء في مخيم نور
شمس في هذه الاثناء حيث وصل الشهداء الى
منازل ذويهم لالقاء نظره الوداعه الاخيره
عليهم ومن ثم الى نادي المخيم من اجل اداء
الصلوات وصلاه الجنازه عليهم ومن ثم للبدء
بعمليه ومراسم التشييع في مخيم نور شمس
ومن ثم على الفور ل مقبره المخيم في مشهد
جنائزي كبير شارك فيه الكل الفلسطيني في
هذه الاثناء هنا في مخيم نور شمس حيث
تواجد مكثف للمواطنين و في هذه الصوره
لربما التي نرصدها على عبر الهواء مباشره
حيث تواجد او نقل احدى الجنازات التي تم
القاء نظره الوداع الاخيره عليه من قبل
ذويه ومن ثم الى يعني نادي المخيم كما
تحدثنا واخيرا الى مثواه الاخير هؤلاء
الشهداء ارتقوا صباح هذا اليوم خلال عمليه
عسكريه لجيش الاحتلال واستهدافهم عبر
طائره مسيره تم استهدافهم بها وهم مدنيين
كانوا يرقبون ماذا يجري من اقتحام داخل
المخيم الان وصلت هذه
الجنازه باصوات التكبيرات للمش
شارع المخيم وصولا الى نادي المخيم من اجل
القاء نظره الوداع الاخير عليهم ايضا من
قبل ذويهم والاقارب
والى المقبره مقبره الشهداء في المخيم من
اجل القاء نظره الوداع الاخيره
عليهم